ce viaduc du boulevard marcel laurin on
constate rapidement que certains camions
passent tout juste patrick doucet de
trois rivières vient de faire une
livraison juste à côté et il se prépare
à repartir genre pro-choix d'hommes
méfier une rapide et ceux qui devaient
ne pas arriver arriva son toit accroche
le viaduc
c'est au moins le septième camion depuis
novembre a heurté la structure selon les
cas signalés en tout cas avoir les
rayures sur le béton du plafond c'est
arrivé souvent les réflecteurs ici
portrait avec la presse les dommages
sont limités sur le camion mais patrick
n'est pas content il ya un méchant brown
surtout que c'était à z de camions qui
tiendrait pas au choix de mérici sur ce
viaduc 31 mille passagers du train vers
de montagne circulent chaque jour de
semaine et chaque accident qui survient
paralyse les trains dès que quelqu'un
nous rapporte une collision avec ce
viaduc là on doit on doit faire les
inspections qui sont nécessaires c'est
certain que moi une vidéo comme ce que
représente aujourd'hui ça ça démontre
l'urgence en fait qu'on identifie la
source du problème éthique on trouve les
solutions
alors nous avons loué ce qu'on appelle
un télémètre laser
on va mesurer la hauteur du viaduc nous
avons pris des mesures à plusieurs
endroits résultat trois mètres 99 soit 4
cm de plus que les 3 mètre 95 indiqué 13
pieds 0,9 pouces ce qui est important
c'est que la ville de montréal est
respectée la hauteur permise
maintenant il ya en voie de la
responsabilité des camionneurs
de ce nom pas se fier à leur habitude
mais à la signalisation qui est existant
j'étais en voiture 3.95 aux avirons
mais pourquoi plus d'accidents
aujourd'hui la ville croit que des
ornières dans le vieil asphalte donner
plus d'espacé aux camionneurs maintenant
que nous avons corrigé le problème de ce
fait on une surface qu'il dise qui est
droite
effectivement il ya peut-être quelques
millimètres de long qui permettent
malheureusement aux camions de ne plus
franchir ce tunnel
pas question pour montréal de refaire la
route la ville souhaite plutôt
sensibiliser les entreprises
industrielles des environs ici jean
sébastien cloutier radio canada montréal